well hey there folks out in podcast land
listen to your podcast this is life is
short before we begin i want to thank
our presenting sponsor bud light selter
we love these drinks so much we can't
stop talking about them so finally they
just thought okay we'll be a sponsor
fine
here's the show
[Music]
in the summer of 2000 20 years ago
i was doing my first big lead role in a
movie called it was called jeepers
creepers and the producer of that movie
was one of my cinematic heroes francis
ford coppola and uh he took everyone out
for a big fancy dinner all i wanted to
know about was uh shooting apocalypse
now or
the outsiders or any of his other movies
i i so badly wanted to hear stories
about about these movies that i loved i
said uh something like oh oh what about
martin sheen in um apocalypse now what
happened when he punched the mirror and
coppola told me the story about it which
was koblett had a dream where martin
sheen was a bunch of uh russian nesting
dolls and he was nothing but a face and
martin sheen was really drunk in this
hotel room and coppola told him about
the dream and so when martin sheen
punched the mirror he was really
punching his own face and he got a he
sliced up his hand had to be taken to
the hospital and had a heart attack it
turns out later and i was just in on and
hearing him tell it and and then there
was just like the silence and i realized
we're at this table and there are
families and there are kids there you
know and he told this like gruesome
crazy story about filmmaking also we're
all about to go make this movie did you
ever work with coppola again no
no
surprisingly no wait why are you
mentioning i'm just curious
[Music]
you are listening to life is short i am
your host justin long life could be a
dream
[Music]
20 year old justin long like a little
yappy puppy like a little eager
just desperate for stories from coppola
yeah i can see it i wasn't there but i
can see it even if you were now 20 years
later if you were on the podcast i'd be
so annoying with him i was annoying
today with our guest who i'm going to
and and our guest today uh the reason
we're talking about coppola was in one
of coppola's most iconic movies uh
the outsiders a movie that i have not
seen yeah you gotta fix that we should
watch it tonight okay um and aren't you
curious to see i said that proudly but
i'm not proud i'm ashamed because i know
it's great it's great and you've read
the book you know i have not read the
book
okay well now should i feel shame maybe
a little okay
but our yes our guest today was in that
movie and ooh you may be a titter now
you may be
so teased uh because not see thomas
howell no it what a great cast though i
mean it could be any number of yeah who
else legends uh matt dylan a lot of
legends in that movie who else is in
that movie tom cruise
um ralph macchio oh yeah diane lane
oof man what do you how do you feel
about diane lane
in that movie i think she's an
incredible personality yeah she's a
great actress
why i don't know you just got really uh
flushed when you said her name well also
i you know i discovered that movie
during a time in my life formative time
when i was the age of those where you
were discovering yourself yeah we don't
have to get into that very slow okay
she's in the movie and she's great in it
and um it's just an incredible cast uh
and yeah that's where my my love affair
with matt dylan began
what oh you mean as an actor oh sorry
yeah i would have told you if i had to
assume an actual level you had a very
crazy affair with matt dylan and you
didn't tell me what if this is how i'm
revealing that and you've known me for
this long wouldn't you be scared oh i i
would leave here right now get in the
car drive away i would need to be by
myself for a couple weeks if i if i was
like if i if you earnestly told me right
now that you had it you had had a crazy
like two year long affair with matt
dillon
and well just telling me now i would i
would like yeah that'd be weird i would
question a lot about my existence
yeah well i i i it would be very hard i
would all have to have been because i
was embarrassed to tell you or
or matt
said he would hurt me if i told him he's
like
god
for the record i have not yet
had an affair with matt dillon we're
both still alive so possible possible um
i i would have i would say it'd probably
be less probable on his hands to want to
engage in that
you're more likely to want to have an
affair with him than vice versa
i think so it's so weird to think it's
weird to think about i mean i uh yeah
but um no my i as an actor i really fell
in love with matt and uh then years
later got to work with him and that was
a thrill but uh
also a thrill to talk to our guest today
who was not matt dillon hopefully one
day will be matt dillon our guest today
is rob lowe the um
really
horrible to look at
um they're very attractive i mean i hate
even mentioning that because we try to
reduce them to that but let's talk about
that let's just get out of the way let's
talk about it now yeah the gorgeous
elephant in the room
i mean one of
i would say the all-time best looking
male faces on the planet oh wow wouldn't
you say yeah yeah it's really tough to
compete with roblox yeah i mean and
continues to and and this is from
someone who
really admires
tom brady's face but i would say rob
lowe is next level he's also really
funny and you guys talk about that i
know so maybe we could talk about that
afterwards okay great you know people
know rob lowe everyone knows rob lowe he
has a new podcast yes called literally
literally literally literally oh you
have to say like that yeah that's how he
says it and okay we talked about that i
didn't realize that because i am well
we'll save it um so we'll talk about the
podcast it's funny to talk about a
podcast on another podcast but uh we've
done it before and i'm sure it'll happen
again uh and of course this incredible
body of work uh dating back i thought
you were gonna say
uh we should also mention his incredible
body of work
um
yeah and his face that
also not not to dwell on his face any
longer but
yeah
but uh is is
changing so well you know is like is
aging in a really like nice way and not
he's not getting all that work done a
lot of guys a lot of guys end up getting
work done but anyway uh admiring for
that and so many more things that we
will get into right now
um my my first
my first encounter you had never met him
never met him uh so it was really cool
to to get to talk to him um also just as
a little heads up
the first
i would say 10 minute 9 or 10 minutes of
the interview oh yeah the audio on his
end for some reason is pretty bad it's
pretty shitty but then
he plugs something in or flicks a button
or something and it's
a million times better so maybe he just
set his gaze on the right part of the
computer maybe and it just turned on
so just as a little warning
if you're annoyed by the first 10
minutes of the sound quality stick it
out and it turns around at minute 10.
and i hope you guys enjoy it here's my
talk with rob lowe
life could be a dream
[Music]
yes yeah i love that
yes
i love that you know you know you know
what it is oh it's wet screen too it's
on the screen but i'm also i'm j-lo
so that's kind of a fun one too
that is a good one look at you hey rob i
have the worst memory in the world do
you recall us meeting ever
i'm the same okay i i don't think we
have i don't think we have i i you're
somebody that i've admired for such a
long time that i
it would be incumbent on me to remember
because i it'd be more likely that i
would remember her uh
because i grew up watching you and
admiring you but but i uh i don't think
that we have it's nice to meet you
you're why are you doing a podcast
i believe in in running my career
backwards
i started out i started out as a big
movie star and then i decided you know
what i'm just going to go to television
and then i was like you know what i'm
just going to become an author and i was
you know what i'm going to go on the
road with my stand up and bang around
and now it's like i'm doing a podcast
yeah with my career what's next where do
you go from there i think it's a
lemonade stand
[Laughter]
[Music]
but a very entertaining a gorgeous
lemonade stand it will be unlike
anything you've witnessed um
the podcast
actually comes from the same place of
like when i when i was like i think i've
got a memoir or two in me but i didn't
really know yeah yeah but i knew it
would be fun and
if it didn't work it would be fun and if
it worked it'd be great exactly well i
did two of them and they both worked
then it was like i think i have a
one-man show
and same i don't know if it'll work but
all fun doing it and if it works it's a
whole other thing for me
i've been played all over the world
national theater london oh you know 2500
seat oh yeah oh wow
i do like 2500 seat theaters oh wow what
what is that experience like rob is that
based on your memoirs then is that just
you is it your life it's in lieu of a
third memoir so like people what people
are like are you gonna do a third book
so i wrote a show and it's it's very
similar to the books but it's
observations and it's literally
storytelling oh that's me telling
telling stories for an hour and a half
and there's some
some clips but they're more for
joke punctuation as opposed to it oh
you're saying those fires yeah yeah are
you gonna be starting that back up when
uh i am whenever we can the whenever we
can get the concert business back going
you know um i will do that i've got a
couple big atlantic city things coming
up oh wow
but the podcast was the same it was like
i
think i have
a podcast in me
because i i've been blessed to know a
lot of
really diverse interesting
people over the 40 years i've been doing
this i have a history with everybody
sure like
from the most random to the most famous
to the most and let's face it no one's
going to talk to gwyneth paltrow
like the guy who who who gave her a room
and board when she was 16 and being out
in l.a trying to find an agent you know
what i mean literally literally yeah so
that and that's also that's the name of
the show
you've always struck me as somebody who
whenever i see you on talk shows and one
now you you seem like you're very
curious and you enjoy
you enjoy talking to people um yeah so
it it makes sense i when i heard that
you were doing it it wasn't like rob
lowe really you seemed like you were a
good fit for that uh what so you've just
been calling friends and being like hey
you want to come on the show
it's been friends so far but you know i
also
but it's also been people that i didn't
know which has been really fun like um
and it's like like us you know we we
don't know each other and we're in it's
but we instantly have a thing going on
so i've
i i've loved i love that but i i got to
say out of the gate
it's just fun to talk to alec baldwin
or or my magic johnson was my is my
going to be my second guest and i'm like
he and i are doing a deep dive of what
we
saw together as friends during the 80s
l.a lakers oh my showtime era i mean
no one's going to talk to magic like i
am right right well can you i mean you
can't really go
that
deep when it comes to stuff like that
right i mean i imagine a lot of stuff
that you saw in the 80s with the brad
pack that there's there's got to be a
finite depth that you can
mine you remember
i mean it's like
for every great story i remember there
are ten that i've forgotten i bet i bet
there i i remember seeing you with kevin
bacon and i think michael j fox there's
there's an amazing set of have you seen
these photos they they were circulating
on the
internet i think the one you're talking
about is judd nelson michael j fox
and me in the back of a bus that's what
it is yeah
yeah how did i throw kevin i remember it
you do remember that
oh
i remember
the three of us are the three most
hungover human beings
in the history of the planet and um
we're on the back of what was called the
hollywood clean water caravan yes
organized by jane fonda and tom hayden
it was the first proposition on the
california proposition ballots ever
passed now of course all they do is do
proposition ballots yeah um and it was
to
um
to label
toxins that would be in the drinking
water
and you know no one knows more about
toxins and drinking yeah than three
hungover actors yes exactly
god i remember those days where you
could be hungover and not really feel it
it was like hey you're a little run down
now i get a hangover and it's like i'm
out for at least two days
no
for sure those days it was like
you know it was like the way i feel
before i get my first cup of coffee
yeah exactly your dad was a trial
attorney did do you think he had
anything to do with your ability to
speak and to
engage in conversation
yeah well he was a because he a trial
attorney as you would say he was a a
word smith and your mom was a teacher
my mom was an english teacher and
and
one of the
you know wrote every day of her life
never bothered to get around to figuring
out what to do with it
she wrote because she needed to had to
enjoyed it wow um like journal
wrote about her life wrote about yeah
journal every day of her life dream
journal
short stories
screenplays
cue and never did anything with it which
i was always a great source of
frustration to me because i'm very
i'm very um
oriented yeah proactive and result
oriented but when she passed away i have
i i inherited all of her
writings and the woman journaled every
day of her life oh my god from probably
1968 to
when she died in 2009.
[Music]
wow rob what a what an incredible
resource
to have of somebody you were so close
with
i'm sure you've gone back and read
uh oh yeah like my brother and i are
like do you remember that weird road
trip we took
i'm like hang on one second oh my god
yep it was a weird road tip
oh my gosh she's very upset with us oh
you were a very bad boy that day oh my
god that's so cool and also potentially
i would imagine
scary to uncover to unearth some of this
stuff
uh
it's definitely the definition of
pandora's box yeah you're not sure you
want to open that thing oh yeah well
especially some of the dream
journals yeah oh yeah
yeah
i wonder what my mother's dreams were
yeah oh god oh i get visuals very easily
too i get like instant visuals and
i'm now imagining some of my own
mother's erotic uh dreams i'm sure
you're in a lot of them
um
you what is that like rob i've always
also wondered this to be
you're somebody who is so often
as talented and smart and all of these
cerebral things that you are you're
often objectified you're one of the guys
that it's like safe to say oh roblo's so
attractive or it doesn't age or these
things and i'm looking at you now and
it's that's true
but
help me as a person who is not in that
position understand what that's like
to i don't want to say deal with it like
it's an affliction but to
spend a life with your face
well there's there's two sides of it
really one is just even the conversation
of it makes me roll my eyes and go
you know it's my [ __ ] face of course
of course yeah right it is what it is i
don't know anything different i mean
there's no real way to answer that to
i'm sorry to even ask without sounding
somewhat douchey like
well just to accept the question is like
you're accepting
that that is a truth but um
let's say it is for argument's sake
my takeaway midlife of of all of this is
is objectification i love that you used
that word because that really is what it
is sure
and and usually the shoes on the other
foot it's frankly it's usually guys
objectifying women yeah right
and i don't know how many guys get
objectified like walk down the street
it's like i've been the person who's
walked down the street and had the
construction workers whistling yeah
totally totally it's like right it's
like you tom brady i could think of
maybe a handful that that applies to
right i mean and it's a thing of like
you go
it's flattering right up into the middle
it's not flattering and when i was a kid
you could still hear me right oh yeah
just in fact i can hear you better now
for some reason you just really came in
when i was
a teen idol
i i was always unsettled by it and i
could never really figure out why it was
so unsettling and it wasn't until years
of therapy
and
getting sober and doing all the work on
myself that i've done over the past 30
years that i realized it was the
objectification yeah
you realize
like it has nothing to do with you you
lose your agency or something
you just happen to be the guy who is
occupying a place in the zeitgeist at
that moment for every hormonal
teenage girl
when you're and when they outgrow you or
you outgrow it they'll be somebody else
right
there about that's been going on
since donovan and elvis and bieber and
leo and it's going to go on and on and
on and you just happen to have a spot on
the conveyor belt half the time they
don't even
know why they like you yeah how quickly
did that happen rob after after the
outsiders that was that was your first
film right when you played
yeah and it actually happened even
before before that because um i did a
network tv series
when i was 15.
and then like three networks yeah and we
were the lowest rated show
on all of television you're right
60 minutes
we had horrible ratings and i looked
back at the ratings and i think we had
15 million people wow
and it was a disaster yeah you know it's
funny i was just even back in the early
2000s i was just talking to julie bowen
we were on a show together called ed
that nobody really saw it got like
middling you know and uh and i brought
that up and she said oh compared to
today's numbers that'd
be a hit it was like eight mil you know
uh like you said there just weren't
choices there just weren't other things
to choose
so 50 million people are watching that
that's enough to change your life that's
enough to change your experience walking
down the street well i remember we used
to shoot in front of a live audience and
you know as you know you shoot shows and
you bank a bunch of them and then they
start airing so the first show we shot
after we aired we heard one episode they
introduced me and
the place went so crazy that they
instituted a rule that nobody under the
age of 20 would be allowed into the
audience again oh my god oh my goodness
and what you do is i go like i'm still
the same guy nothing changed
a year i'm still the same guy who went
to santa monica high school and
look it's not like i didn't have
girlfriends i did but you know i wasn't
in the cool group all the girls loved
the athletes and the volleyball players
and i wasn't a theater nerd you may have
seen yourself that way but do you ever
look back or do your friends who look
back and say
no what are you talking about you were
you were handsome and cool you were like
girls wanted you and
i'm telling no no they really don't
really my friend that it was it was a
different time first of all there were
not everybody was an actor it was it
business was still such that
it hadn't pivoted 100 to being a total
glorification of youth so
there were child actors
now every
child is an actor right that's true
that's true tic tac um
yeah
and was your brother doing it at the
same time were you guys kind of coming
up together chad
we're really close still are um he's
four years younger than me so
he wasn't in doing any acting or
anything like that he he and charlie
sheen they were best friends and and
they were they were going to be
professional baseball players that was
my god oh my god
that's fine that's funny does he still
play do you ever play with him
on a softball league um i've played with
they both are really good charlie was
really good really probably throw in the
90s
oh my god it looked good really good wow
so sorry to jump around so much robert
that did that tv show lead to coppola
seeing you for the outsiders well i only
learned this later in life
that what happened was coppola asked for
all of the teenage pinups
to be put on a montage board so we could
look at them to be literally pinned up
literally pinned up yeah why
me being on that show turned me into a
teen idol which put my magazines which
put me on the magazine where
his casting director went and here's
this one so
you know it would have been me and
willie ames yeah he's got mayo and leif
garrett and
matt dillon and um that was part of wow
this is for the outsiders and then of
course you had to go in and audition and
read and do all that stuff so it was
just you and i imagine a room full of
like who's who in early 80s hollywood
just in a room kind of duking it out
like a like mix and match type of thing
it was a total mix and match and it was
everybody from
dennis quaid oh wow mickey rourke they
were on the older end and mickey when
mickey was like
the next great white hope yeah yeah
um
all the way down to like
the kid who started e.t
oh yeah and
and every time it's wow wow
i'm i mean that's when i fell in love
with movies so this is
i just talking to you about this
it's a thrill i'm really i'm gonna try
to prevent myself from nerding out too
much uh
but but you must have been were you
what was your confidence level like i'd
imagine for a 15 16 year old kid to be
in a room with coppola who at the time i
think he was coming off of apocalypse
now and
you know there didn't get any bigger
than that what did that feel like being
in that room not to mention being in a
room with matt dillon and these guys
that you probably
knew
yeah it was um well
the stakes were really really high um
really intimidated by francis
um
everybody wanted it so badly
and you know we were all friends by that
point me cruz emilio
some of the others and we would go in
for for days to audition dave wow really
wow and mixed in reading the script you
would just exchange parts i i've just
seen some of the i was just watching
hearts of darkness uh well that's why i
always wondered about coppola post
apocalypse now if like
he was more maybe relaxed and just had
this ease
with his directing style no see i
thought all movies were made the way
francis made movies right because i
didn't know any better and
you know he he would
when we finally got the part i remember
he would make us go play tackle football
in the street
because he wanted to toughen us up oh my
god i remember tommy howell god bless
him whose dad was a stunt man and tommy
was
although he was the youngest he in many
ways was the most experienced because
he'd grown up on sets yeah
tommy huddled us all up and said [ __ ]
this i'm
hitting i'm not doing this
and if francis fires me over it so be it
because what will happen is i'll break
my leg yeah he'll get fired
wow so um
you know france
he was fascinating had amazing ideas and
did things that no other director would
have thought of tried to do and on and
it was it was
it was
were you guys improvising any of that or
was it all pretty heavily scripted we
improvised the entire movie and francis
was the first person ever to use video
or video assist or a monitor oh my god
the first person
on that movie on the he used it on that
movie wow video assists the entire in
the whole thing on a monitor
and that's when people directors were
still sitting right by the lens yeah
yeah wow
um and we shot the entire movie on a
green screen at least twice before we
ever shot it for real what
and i only learned later that that was
because the there was a hiccup in the
financing
and he didn't want to release the cast
i just thought that francis wanted to do
a month of rehearsals i didn't really oh
my god all this it's all this crazy
because you know the bank was
foreclosing on him because of one from
the heart you know right that musical
that he did right that like was just way
over oh that's right he did outsiders
after god see i always imagine he did
outsiders because he lost his shirt on
one from the heart and so he needed
something more commercial 100 there was
a notion that you know
this was francis's idea of what a
commercial movie would be
yeah so there was a little bit of
calculation in it in that way but then
you know he's an artist so he brought
that that level to it and he wanted
he would always tell you he was trying
to make gone with the wind ironically
not hilarious that's what he would be
making wow
wow you need to make gone with the wind
for teens if you look at the stay gold
sequence it literally is the same image
from with god as my witness i shall
never go hungry oh in the background i
i've been meaning to rewatch that uh
i've been watching in quarantine i've
been watching all these old some of my
old revisiting my favorites and uh
that's one i'd i'd like to go back and
see uh
and then rumblefish i was really into as
well similarly uh green ironically
because they they shot them back to back
oh wow and rumblefish was the one
everybody that was the cool one to be in
oh snyder's was sort of considered
the bubble gum teeny bop uh
even though that that book was way way
more of a
bigger hair
but but rumblefish was
definitely considered
the cool one to be added
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wandery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
when you're working that intimately with
those that with that kind of a cast
you must have forged lifelong
friendships i mean you must still be
friends with those guys i was 17 years
old
it was the first time i'd ever left my
own home been away from my family wow i
turned 18 on the set and it's the
equivalent of if you had frat brothers
and lived in and were in a fraternity
yeah that's what it was regardless of i
see them i don't see them i haven't seen
them in years when i run into any of
them we're frat brothers and we have
that that connection that nobody can can
take away and we immediately
are bonded right back to where we were
when we were 17 18 and 19. you just
started tackling each other in the
street that would have boxing matches in
the hallway of the
of the uh i don't know what we've almost
been out of here well listen 17 18 99
yeah yeah
yeah i would expect it'd be weird if you
guys were all like no we were very uh
you know responsible um yeah oh my god
that was in tulsa where'd they shoot
that in oklahoma holster all in tulsa
wow wow with aaron sorkin's west wing
how did that happen and and was that
something that you were resistant to to
doing tv
it was an era it's almost hard to
imagine now yeah i know yes
tvs has supplanted movies now yeah
there was a moment in time where being
on television was like considered a
second-rate hacky medium
yeah that was the culture of right up to
the beginning of the west wing it was
very much stigmatized that's true it was
in fact i would say that that's one of
the shows that started to turn that
stigma
i it for sure was because i can tell you
that from
kiefer sutherland in 24
to william peterson and csi all the guys
took me aside and said
watching what you did on west wing made
me want to do this
wow but when i read the script there was
no doubt i mean when i read the script
as i don't care if they this is on
tv movies backyard theater this script
is so good i can't wait to be a part of
this and had you seen any of erin's work
before had you seen a few good men or uh
i auditioned for malice
which is
what did people forget about alec
baldwin right yeah alec baldwin got the
part did you guys talk about that
uh yeah alex
when alec and i did my alec did my
podcast a week i knew you were up for it
i had heard you were up for it i was
very nervous
just on a total sidebar i my wife was
the leading makeup artist of her for men
and she was alex
makeup artist
on glen gary glenn ross oh you know alec
mentioned her
on the show yeah
yeah why there was on glenn gary yeah he
was and i got i went to visit her and
the two days that i happened to be there
were the only two days
that alec was on the movie and i watched
alex shoot
what i think is one of the greatest
performances yeah tree of acting and
that's his always be closing speech you
know what it takes to kill real estate
wow
that's cool what was that like i i've
got to see the out i love outtakes more
than anything and to see those outtakes
what a thrill that would be
oh well i can tell you what it was like
those guys were not having it
really [ __ ] no like who's this [ __ ]
who's a handsome like young guy coming
in and [ __ ] on us exactly
that they were not acting
wow and um
and then uh
alec told me this story which is so
funny um
uh
what uh
hang on not jack lemmon ed harris uh
alan r
because he does a good arcane impression
he does a good he said he said
he said there was a moment during the
day he said to alan you know it's going
to be rough i'm going to yell at you and
i think you're great whenever
and then uh
alan was was in his dressing room i
think talking on the phone and being
loud and alec was trying to talk to him
and he knocked on his door and said mr
arkan i'm so sorry i'm just i'm just on
the phone do you mind and and art goes
out there
in here
my god
yeah yeah out there in here yeah
the version he told me was that he said
that as a result of uh alec asking in
the makeup show i think they were
talking about like hey how do you think
that movie did or like they were talking
about box office [ __ ] or like
you know some kind of chit chat about
the industry and that's what prompted
him to say
oh there
wasn't he doing the same it's suck he's
telling the same stories at different
packs
listen when you have a grip when you
have a great
play the hits oh i have like ten i
reside circulate yeah oh yeah sure yeah
and and whenever you can do an
impression like that even if the story's
not great
which this one is it's all an excuse
exactly exactly exactly
uh yeah well that must be another thing
about now i'm dwelling on this like teen
idol stuff and moving out of that and
transitioning and being reduced to
something because in addition to being
smart you're also very funny and i
remember like when
parks and rec started people were
the vibe was always like oh rob or even
like tommy boy like oh rob lowe gets the
joke roblo's really funny i remember
seeing ryan phillippi and mcgruber and
being like shocked that he got the joke
somebody so attract
when did that start when did that
perception uh as far as you can tell
start changing for you
it was for sure um
when lauren michaels
took me under his wing for sure
first time i hosted snl
which was a dream and
you know i what snl meant to me
as a kid growing up
comedy all of it is impossible to to
overstate and then to be able to host it
and then
for lauren out of all the hosts that
come and go
to to sort of pluck me
and put me in that in that
tight world of mike myers and dana and
um
you know and far right because
you did a bunch of i mean you were in
wayne's right you i i would you would
always be like popping up in those
really funny movies um
yeah so that was all lauren who just
it was all lorne and a little mike myers
because um we hit it off
the first time we met when you when you
host
you know you get to you go into the
writers rooms and you meet with each
writer and you pitch ideas and the hosts
can be either as involved or not
involved as they want and i always loved
being involved and i remember meeting
mike
um the very first time i hosted and he
said to me do you want to do a wayne's
world or do you want to do a sprockets
oh that's so [ __ ] cool i mean either
way that's it's so cool
and we did a sprockets because
yeah i was like huge sprockets me too
yeah
and then later on i i did wayne's world
the movie ah that is so [ __ ] cool
what what oh man was it hard i'm i'm
going to be like chris farley in the
chris farley show yeah talking about
chris farley showtime
when when uh chris farley and the chris
farley show had uh paul mccartney
mccartney oh god
oh my god
what does he say to him when he's like
uh
yeah
when you play a song backwards it says
you're dead paul is dead is that true
yeah um but what makes something like
that great is like what boo like
the the perfect balance to a character
like that is
which people don't give credit to is
paul mccartney being oh yes chris i
think actually you know i do think in
the end the love you take is equal to
the
being totally straight and
that is something that you were doing so
well in
tommy boy wayne's world the saturn live
uh era movies like the golden era of
saturn live
so i i as an actor i see that and i know
that you get it i know that but were
people did people continue to be
surprised by your say things like whoa
he's funny and it is the gift that keeps
on giving yeah no one has made more hay
out of low expectations
than me
that's funny
you know yeah that's funny this day
people were like i didn't know you were
so funny
by the way and i'm glad i'm i'm honestly
whether it's the books
the show whatever like
people just don't expect much from me so
it's perfect
because yeah you lower the expectations
and even if you're just mediocre people
are thrilled you win
because you are funny was it difficult
then on west wing i imagine
i mean probably the opposite of the
coppola experience in terms of improv
like improv and it's not like parks and
rec it must have been so rigid right
i've heard those stories about him which
is a whole other discipline and i'm i i
love
the fact that that i can can
you know swim in both pools yeah sorkin
world where it is
it's about executing a beautiful
symphony
difficult symphony
and you have to trust your instrument
and know when it's your part and
you know no one to be under no one to be
over and and
but knock it out of the [ __ ] park
every single time
or on parks and rec where it's jazz
and
you know you're you're kind of make you
know not that we made it up because mike
shurer wrote everything and
99.9 percent of everything that was ever
in parks was mike sure and that amazing
writer oh really was insane yeah i mean
we would do
what we called fun run improv yeah
um and stuff would famously make it into
the show but i think people would be
shocked at how much of parks and rec was
the amazing
wow that is surprising i mean it's a
testament to the acting too because it
felt so kind of off the cuff organic in
those testimonials always felt so like
improv
yeah no that we we would do them and
sometimes they would
and it felt improv and it was very loose
even though it was like loose it was not
sorkin where i remember one day we were
doing one of those 11-page walk-in talks
with characters folding in and folding
out the camera and then going down a
spiral staircase and then through a
kitchen and to a loading dock and a
limousine going away and
and somebody had the line
it was written hmm comma i think so
i said ah i think so and aaron's like
nope we're going again oh
this is the steadicam guys like are you
[ __ ] kid
oh god
wow and i i always imagined to be i've
never done a sorkin thing but to be in
one of those shots like like you said an
11 page walk and talk with the study
to have like a small part it's a small
like a line in that must be
the worst no you want to have you don't
want to have the small part you want to
because then if you [ __ ] up it's fine
but you don't want to be and i remember
this vividly sometimes we would
we'd be on the set
and
the one thing that always made me laugh
about the the west wing is oftentimes
we'll walk past the same door twice only
to open
that [ __ ] door
because you'd run out of real estate you
ran out or so you do the hallway twice
and then walk into it
walking into the oval office that's
funny so you you'd be sitting there and
you'd hear them coming
and then you hear them coming
and the door would open and you'd go yes
mr president and like if and you just
that the heart oh when of not wanting to
[ __ ] up
take that's already been going on for
five minutes oh yeah oh yeah and and
actors it's sort of like i i guess it's
akin to i remember the first time i went
surfing my friend was like in malibu
he's like he's a really good surfer he's
like just come i i was like i think i
should stay in the baby waves he's like
just come out you trial by fire you got
to just like get yourself out there so i
did and a bunch of these surfers that
i've been
talking to beforehand we had been going
there with were so cool and chill and i
got perpendicular to two of their
surfboards and i [ __ ] up both of their
waves and
i thought they were going to drown me i
thought they were going to murder me
like i'm not not even exaggerating they
were livid and i think actors can
to a certain extent get like that if you
[ __ ] up an actor especially like
thinking of some of the people on that
show i'm sure there were you know i
worked with richard schiff i'm sure
there was you know
i i love richard i love it i love it you
went right you know you know it would be
richard i love you richard and i you
know what the word um uh uh you know he
richard's richard's tough
i i'd say it to his face i tell him yes
yeah
i'd flinch as i was saying it but i uh
yeah it's it's just i remember one the
thing i did with richard the director
who was really great director great guy
was like okay we were pressed for time
it was a low budget thing he was like
okay uh richard you're gonna come over
here uh and say the line and he said and
and richard goes
why
and he said
well you're just cause the character's
here and you gotta you gotta come here
and he said why
and everybody got really tense and in
richard's defense he needed a reason it
could have been a and i think they ended
up making it as simple as well you're
bringing a plate over there something
simple but it was like
he needed it and he he was i remember
the director was kind of a younger guy
and he was like uh he started really
panicking uh
he can be tough yeah but hello
as you also know having done tv
that schedule
eats you alive
and i always like to say if you see if
you have a performance that you like
on television by television i don't mean
streaming that's that's movies now
network
television there's a performance you
even remotely like that person's a
[ __ ] acting genius yeah
yeah because it is
such a buzz saw yeah all of the things
that we do as actors
to to to properly deliver a performance
are
that it's not a culture that supports it
so when richard schiff asks why which is
absolutely what he should do totally
yeah
the fact that we were able to take the
time and answer those questions on the
west wing and that was the culture
that's crazy it was really really
extraordinary because yes we were there
to serve aaron but the culture of acting
was taken deadly seriously oh i bet and
then so you go from west wing park
bouncing around but so many great things
rob oh really quickly superficially i
i'm dying to ask you when you saw um
when you saw austin uh the original
austin powers
and and you heard they were doing like
uh
when you saw robert wagner had you done
a robert wagner impression prior to that
so what happened was mike and i
became best friends after wayne's world
so very much in each other's lives and
um
when mike was
debating doing austin powers he created
the character and did it for a week at
the groundlings
i'd give notes and we would talk and it
was unclear really what it was going to
be or not
and then he wrote the script and the
script was great
um and i loved that and i had a bit part
in it just for fun that got cut that's
in the extended version which is cool
which is it's a really fun really fun
sequence i want it's very elaborate
setup to describe it i won't board it oh
and i'll see it yeah it's in the it's in
the deleted stuff yeah but so and then
robert wagner obviously is in it and i'd
known rj
for years because melissa gilbert
and katie wagner and his daughter were
best friends
so
i on any given friday i was at rj's
house drinking vodka with rj oh my god
oh my god and so
i had done
an rj impression
for for years and years and years and
i'll never forget remember what we were
golfing up here at sandpiper mike and i
talking about austin powers and i was
talking about rj and i did my
impersonation for mike
and he called loved it so he called us
then wife said you have to hear this and
they laughed and it was all big
kerfuffle and i didn't think anything of
it and then six months later the script
of austin powers 2 was sent to me by
mike
and he had written me into it that's
cool robert wagner that's hot
had you ever done that impression for
robert wagner never and i was scared too
i bet i bet i do impressions of people
that i really admire and matt was
somebody i watched you know uh yeah man
i did i'm sure you do you do it
hey man thanks yeah thank you that's
really good
but i
we were doing a movie together and one
of the makeup ladies was like oh matt
have you heard justin's impression of
you what are you talking about man i
mean he got and it got
a little weird i'll tell you a longer
story next time i say but but yeah i did
it yeah i i've been caught i've been
called out by him
and i i love him but he was like hey man
enough all right
enough with the impression yeah so good
but you know what i love about your
impression you just did is there's
it's him but there's something there's
an essence that you got doesn't mean
like
there's a channeling sort of aspect to
it a lot of this yeah
hey man yeah
it's a lot of like stretching
yeah it's very tactile you know where
that all started that started with
francis feeding matt brando movies day
in and day out
oh intro think about it how is i wish we
were doing it
but this this chin thing yeah rob's
sticking his chin out yeah nothing more
than brando oh my god oh my god i i
floated down that river once as a young
man it's smartest gardenias oh my god
that's really good yeah that's where it
is
that's interesting i had heard that
because he
you know france just he he got plucked
from obscure you know he was
oh my god and then he's wow did you ever
get into i know he's sort of he
fetishized that actor studio world and
got deep into that did did that happen
did you know that's a very new york
thing you know
that's miss you know very new york and i
was la and i don't think the actor's
studio had an la
uh presence until years later
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
what do you miss most about parks and
rec people love that show i'm sure
people come up to you all the time it it
seems like let me ask you a more general
question remember michael j fox saying
something like this when people would
approach him just strangers would
approach him about the movies
there was something more timid about the
nature of their approach versus tv when
you started doing tv did you find people
were more familiar with you and treated
you such it's funny because i remember
michael and i were rivals for a moment a
brief moment in time
he didn't like me very much yeah
um
and i remember going to um i want to say
the hagler hearns fight oh the fight
yeah and you know how they always
introduce the celebrities and goodness
tonight is you know whoever and
so michael's sitting in front of me i've
not met him
and he's sitting in front of me and they
introduce him and he waves and then they
introduce me
and then he whips around and he's like
oh so there you are mr brat pack i guess
my uh
my invitation got lost in the mail
that's okay because i got my own thing
going the snack pack anyway so we hit it
off and we were friends ever since oh
good okay wait so he was he was being
cheeky i thought like he's the best and
so yeah i remember one of the first
times we were hanging out
um you know he was i think
back to the future had not even really
come out yet and he was alex p keaton of
family ties and we pulled up in a car
together
and the group of girls or whatever
looked at us
and
mike fox said
look the way they relate to me versus
the way they relate to you
because he says i'm in their t i'm in
the tv i'm in their living room you're
up on the big screen and michael fox was
told me that same story and that and i
think that he's absolutely right there's
a
notion of familiarity of intimacy that
you've yeah in people's homes yeah and
then a larger than life quality in the
movies and also back then as you
mentioned the teen idol phenomenon was
was
in full effect and so these girls
deified you in a way i mean they were
literally like you were part of their
iconography they were putting you on
their wall and
i would say you're surprisingly down to
earth only in the sense that you
for so long were inundated with
that adulation and adoration um
so that must take a toll psychologically
that's nice of you to say and i i mean i
like i think you don't survive very long
in this business without perspective
yeah and um and you gotta like know take
it for what it's worth and you know what
we do i actually think it's more
important now than it's ever been to
give people comfort and remind each
other of our
shared humanity and and escape from the
from daily life but
we're also playing dress up for a living
right let's be clear and yeah and uh so
i think the people that have a really
good perspective on it are the people
who at the end of the day can survive it
did you
did that take was there a turning point
in your career when you had to uh
adopted because of the result of let's
say not working as much or
um just moving from teen idol a
different phase that that was not maybe
you weren't as popular or whatever
did do you remember moments where you
really had to take stock of where you
were psychologically oh god yeah look i
spent the 80s building my career yeah
90s building
my development which you know there's
that that saying and i believe it's true
that however old you are when you become
famous
is where you are stuck
so if you come famous at 15 you're a 15
year old for the rest of your life
unless you do serious work on yourself
i think there's a lot
and so for me i i would be i i was
trapped
like in uh i was like han solo and
carbonite
at probably an 18 year old rat packer
yeah
and you get into your mid-20s and if you
get a glimmer of awareness and realize
that's what you are
you know you're at that fork in the road
where you can go okay i can be that guy
or
i can grow and have different interests
and be more well-rounded and actually
have a family and i'm sure i was gonna
say meeting your wife was probably a
huge uh
for sure these are gonna be lightning
round quick questions
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say
oh i i'm i this stupid original yellow
colored thumbs up great i'm just stupid
and easy and just want it off my desk
yeah yeah good i like that it's it's
user
um if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play you
mentioned baseball or chad played
baseball
well surfing
baseball's my favorite
and then
oh
geez i don't know because i i'm obsessed
with surfing
and i would love to be a big wave surfer
i would have loved to have done that um
i'm obsessed with golf
um but then you go was it about making
is it about what's can i also make money
and not kill myself yeah like what would
you do yeah exactly that should be part
of it i guess
well if it's just pure ability yeah and
like being able to do something i would
i would love to be
um a professional
golfer or professional surfer are you
and chad
are you said you're close to was there
ever a moment i have two brothers both
of whom
were actors at one point did was there
ever weirdness between you guys in terms
of like oh [ __ ] i wanted that part or
you know uh
there was the only weirdness was really
when i was
and i think it was more sibling rivalry
than anything as i started getting
famous at 18.
you know chad was you know four years
but yeah
and he and charlie used to roll their
eyes at emilio and i oh really like
those hollywood guys
there's hollywood guys oh really
we're going to mickey owens baseball
camp in missouri so they're eating their
sushi and doing their show business and
the next thing you know they're both
actors
yeah that's funny
uh dude were you up for young guns were
you like you [ __ ]
no i don't know where my my offer for
young guns was
one of those things like what the living
[ __ ]
do you think emilio blackballed me
without me knowing probably
i think he might have that's well we
should if not we should get that rumor
going uh yeah some controversial brat
pack rumor
uh if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life what would it be
by the way i love your reaction to that
i i wish people could see that reaction
yeah okay i could tell you you just like
deflated like this is going to be too
hard
it's too hard yeah i mean
my my the hill that i die on
in terms of health and eating well is it
it's it's ice cream above all
with without a doubt that's that's my
kryptonite there was a moment during
this covet thing where i
became aware that i was
in my third trimester with an ice cream
baby
[Laughter]
and so i was going to have a big gender
reveal
you're not supposed to do that anymore
by the way you can't even do that
anymore yeah
that's up to them
um but i was going to have a naming
party but i i i i was going to name my
baby haagen-dazs oh that makes sense
that's sweet
um huh that's also gross um
well the next thing is gross yeah i know
well i'm also a little lactose
intolerant so it conjures images of like
just like pushing out gas the kind of
gas where you're like
unscrewing a radiator and it's like
i remember that feeling after like a
date you know when you like are just
sitting on whatever indigestion you're
working through and it's like then when
you leave whenever you leave the house
or whatever it's like you're alone in a
car
yeah
you can feel yourself like your body
like changing um this the next question
i often get shamed for and nobody shamed
me worse than alec when i asked him you
can imagine it's what's what's your
favorite movie of all time if you have
one
are you kidding me
yeah he was coughing a lot it was
get the [ __ ] man a loss
it was it was
would it be so hard for alec baldwin to
get a lozenge
i know i i it was also pre-coveted so i
wasn't as like squirrely about it
yeah no exactly um he was like it would
be something with marty
by the way
and for me it is marty yeah
it's good it's good fellas
yeah yeah
uh you and jonah hill
um if you
if you had to live somewhere else oh you
must have
if you had to live somewhere else you
live in
do you live in malibu now i live in i
live in montecito so that's santa
barbara yeah oh cool um where where else
would you live if you could pick another
place here's the good news i know this
is the best place in the i i
in the
this is it but um
i have
like
here's my fantasy like
hudson river valley
rolling estate down to the hudson river
valley the best there's i got i got a
part of me that could be on the
intercoastal waterway in key largo
yeah oh i could do that
i got a part of me that could live on a
you know a
1780
farmhouse on the outskirts of nashville
yeah
great
horse country of virginia i i definitely
have um oh i'm on board with all of
those uh
fantasies living fantasies um
so good if you could have dinner with
three people dead or alive whom you've
never met who would they be
jfk uh-huh
um
he's the first one
three people it's real it's always such
a hard one that's why i never did the
damn proust questionnaire and vanity
fair because
all that stuff don't give you time for
that
they do but you also but sometimes the
more time you have like then you start
like second guessing and wanting to
sound but you know uh i know that's a
tough one it's a tough lightning round
one i'm gonna go i'm gonna go um
it's really hard because people like
like like i'm a huge paul newman fan i
knew him a little bit wow
he he wasn't
anonymous about it but he's not like
overly personable well that's the thing
it's like this is operating under the
assumption that like you know
abraham lincoln or or thurgood marshall
are going to be like great dinner
conversationalists and not
whereas like a good example of that how
that's not often the case i did have
dinner with coppola
he produced this movie i was doing and i
was trying to just every chance i got i
was bringing up movies and it's the last
thing he wanted to talk about you just
want to talk about wine and pasta you
know yeah that's the and he hasn't
changed yeah um yeah
so it's going to be a it's just going to
be me and jfk at uh at the apple pan on
a stool okay all right all right we're
getting the cheeseburger yeah um uh okay
who's your favorite muppet
oh
one 100
kermit dude when kermit sings the
rainbow connection it's all over yeah
it's all up it's done uh that's true
that's true uh if you could have one
superpower what would it be
to fly of course yep okay also correct
um and uh if you could be one age for
the rest of your life physically
speaking what would you pick
i would be happy to be exactly as i am
now i i for me it's anywhere from it's
not really fair to ask you that question
i think i think like
47 was a really good good year in terms
of
the the balance of like
mental physical
spiritual career that's pretty cool
honestly i i i would
now would be great too i i definitely
don't want to go back to teen idol or
brat pack
sure i don't yeah
um if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would it be what
what animal do you identify with dolphin
okay
[Music]
sure
that was funny
yeah okay that makes sense all the time
they like sex very smooth
they're smooth and they know how to surf
waves
people like touching them people they
make you ha
seeing the dolphin is like releases
something in your body like hearing a
baby laugh it's really true that's a
good point that's true yeah you get like
they make you like giddy yes
um would you rather be again not fair to
ask you this but would you rather be
called unattractive or unfunny
ooh
oh i'd rather definitely be called
unattractive yeah unfunny would be
the lowest form of misery yeah yeah
especially if it's somebody you if it's
like larry david or somebody you know
yeah killer
um oh god i'm just picturing that now
literally that uh which which golden
girl do you most identify with dorothy
blanche rose or sophia
dorothy was b arthur blanchard br i'm a
big b arthur person i'm a big i use mod
and b arthur as a touchstone all the
time
would that be one of your favorite
herald and mo i just saw it for the
first time recently
harold mod is great you know
i mean that's my son just watch it's
great oh yeah
i'm a big b arthur person do your sons
go back and watch your stuff do they
have they seen all your stuff
um my youngest one john owen has never
seen a frame of the west wind
what
oh my god
he does it just to to get go
i have a theory and this i encountered
this twice now on the show that it was
correct see what you think of this it
was during a time in your career
when they were young they were like and
that show brought you away from them
took you away from them so maybe the
subconsciously they're like [ __ ] that
show that was responsible for dad not oh
wait you know
i think that's
that's that's really true i have i have
chris pratt on the first episode of my
podcast and he and i he's married to
catherine schwarzenegger oh right
catherine schwarzenegger is
um my god daughter oh my god and
daughter and uh god daughter yeah and
she's very funny about she's never seen
like true lies
weird wait
what
well i'm sure she's seen some of the
stuff i'm sure she's seen terminator
predator this is the other one like
other than arnold have you not seen
every movie that arnold schwarzenegger's
been in well maybe similar maybe that
was during i don't know but it is that
formative years it's like it's like it's
like i i get it it doesn't it's not a
part of their entertainment sphere it's
the part of their
fam family sphere exactly and so they're
not you know whatever and maybe
responsible too the other weirdness
julie bone mentioned this was that when
people would come up would kind of
bother you guys when you're out i'm sure
it happens to you all the time uh when
people approach you and want pictures
now as everyone's got cameras i'm sure
it's like oh the west wing is also kind
of responsible for that yeah screw that
[ __ ] up yeah [ __ ] the west wing uh but
he should watch it because he's isn't he
a filmmaker or he he's working he's uh
he's a he's a writer on 9-1-1 lone star
oh cool okay well just for that alone
you should watch it um
uh the beatles or the rolling stones do
you prefer the same exact question i ask
people oh yeah i do i like it
it's
100 the beatles yes minus two yeah but i
like when people qualify that uh for
whatever reason oh interesting there is
a qualification to it like that
the
the rolling stones are the world's
greatest rock and roll band
and i never saw the beatles live i've
seen paul live a bunch yeah i'm a little
bit but there's no one like when the
rolling stones are on stage you're like
holy [ __ ] that's rolling stones yeah and
there's no one like that
nobody comes close on the other side of
it though
it's pound for pound musical legacy
you know songwriting
you're not going to ever top london
mccartney as songwriters
i think a more difficult question is for
me it's either is bob dylan or the
beatles or bruce springsteen in the
beatles that would be more challenging
bruce is my guys i mean i'm i'm
i you know my people ask me what's your
proudest thing you've ever done i say my
set list when i hosted e street radio
oh cool that's cool i'm serious that's
cool
that's fun that's awesome i you also
have a similar
genetic makeup in the sense that you're
still there's there's this vitality that
you both have i mean i saw him on stage
it's not 10 years ago but he was i think
into his 60s at the time maybe late 50
and he did over three hours and it was
like
at the sweat and it was tiring just
watching him
yeah he's been a a real inspiration to
me and on a lot of levels i don't know
him well but i've known him
peripherally for
many many many years and and i've i've
taken a lot of cues yeah
do you know him well enough to ask you
to ask him to do the podcast i've
already asked him yeah
we yeah yeah okay oh and i want to i
want to listen to that one and uh hear
your i'm sure you do an impression
of him
yeah it's mostly like this
it's a lot of laughing yeah it's good
that's good yeah he seems like a joyous
person um
as to you i'm so glad we got to really
do this like this was this was a thrill
for me so thank you
yeah me too this is great i i i i feel
like our our shows are simpatico really
yeah i'm excited to hear yours it
launched well today
today
it's uh every thursday great uh uh
literal literally literally every third
why'd you call it that what made you
decide to call it that it was that's the
my parks and rec catchphrase
okay
okay so people say that to you often
when they come up to you
yeah it's i've i've never had a
catchphrase it's been however many years
of being in the business
and the fact that i got one on parks and
rec made me made me laugh and also there
is it is literally
a podcast yeah oh so you say literally
well that's the thing is i say it's a
stupid list
okay all right
did that just become i always wonder how
catch phrases work like did i do that
we'd talk about a lot did that happen
organically i mean it was literally
literally was just something you said on
the show and then they were like oh
it's apparently um
it's apparently according to mike sure
it's he noticed that i overused the word
a lot oh
and that i really leaned in on it
whenever i said it and that i did that
not exactly correct
uh pronunciation
oh oh oh but you would do the correct
usage see that's what bothers me
well and also not that either but here's
one of my favorite most proud of is
chris traeger my character's yusuf
literally was so
uh specific and not
correct that the dictionary change
amended wow the definition of literally
because of that
that's influence
yeah
it ain't bragging if you've done it
yeah well you've done a lot of great
stuff and and uh i am going to be
bragging about having uh had this
conversation with you because i just so
enjoyed it and um
i thank you
jl
you're the man rolo
yolo
uh and oh and profile cobalt sells
itself
yeah oh yeah you're wearing a profile
shirt
and it's on my mug as i speak well say
no more i'm buying it
uh and that also changes the genetic
makeup of your face right if you were to
apply this stuff
my head on your neck right okay five to
ten days okay well i'll see you then
uh and uh thanks buddy that really i
could have fun with the podcast i will
for sure obviously that'd be great i
would i would love that okay
thanks man thanks rob
[Music]
you're sweating too why are you why did
you say it like seductively i didn't did
that happened
now you're flooded now you're
embarrassed you tried you were
projecting your own
flusteredness i'm just calling it like i
see it
and i after hearing that it felt like i
was on
a date not on a date i was like
observing a really nice interaction
between two guys who are hitting it off
oh really yeah
yeah i guess we just hit it off like
yeah you were like flirting with him
am i wrong
you were straight up flirting with him
really yeah what do you mean
you were like giddy around him i was
giddy yeah yeah i
i
re-listened to the part
where um i'm just very charmed by him
yeah i could tell what do you mean
flirting though how was well you had
talked about how you um
you had talked about how you had never
met him before for the record i have had
a bud light i'm i'm almost done with the
bud light seltzer
oh that's that's why you're all a little
bit off the little truck um so you had
talked about how you had never met each
other and
and oh and i was like i would remember
that yeah you're like i don't remember
that like you wouldn't remember it but i
don't know that's true and he goes he's
like yeah but you know i think we have a
good thing going here yeah and when he
said i think we have a good thing i
think i forgot exactly how he phrased it
i think he was yeah we have a good thing
going on here we're connecting or
something
we're hitting it off i could hear your
excitement in in the silence well i i
i really like him i know i get it he's
very charming yeah he's very cool he's
cool and
he'd be i'd like to be and doesn't take
himself too seriously how how attractive
is that i mean he's such an attractive
quality yeah yeah when somebody who
looks like that who could i mean let's
face it most the people who are in that
category like a nine like a ten he's a
nine i only said a nine or a ten but
he's
anyone calls him a nine is out of their
minds um
tens i don't want to generalize but for
the most part i would imagine i mean it
makes sense that they never really have
to cultivate as much of a sense of humor
or a self-effacing personality he
somehow did well which again is why he
testament to his parents it's also why
people uh have
low expectations yeah exactly for him
comedy and he's taken advantage of that
yeah
people probably they look at someone
like that and they're like oh he's
probably
like a mimbo yeah kind of doll and he's
skated by in his looks yeah but he's
actually really funny really funny yeah
i know that was something i started
noticing in the 90s i think we've gotten
into it too much in the interview but i
remember that being being struck by that
being like my perception of him
and also throughout you know sex lies
and videotape and then this the scandal
that was a big scandal now they're
you know
so i mean they've been like you don't
think about that anymore when you think
about rob lowe but as a child of the 80s
that was a huge story and
well he was bad bad boy yeah yeah he had
that image he's confident in himself but
he also
how do i put this he also doesn't
take his uh celebrity or his former teen
idol status
as anything more than
just like a thing that happened to him
he doesn't deny it he doesn't deny it
but he also doesn't uh like revel in it
yeah that's true
in fact if anything he reduces it to
this passing
superficial thing that you know he was
on this path at some point along with
bieber and uh you know well all these
guys uh these teen idols and it's it's
fleeting i think that's the only healthy
way to internalize something like that
because the the alternative is really
actually scary and i've seen that
manifest in people too that the former
teen idols right that they're holding on
well that's he says that that that was
really interesting with high school
football stars too ten years ago yeah i
never heard that before the idea that
when someone becomes famous they get
stuck at the age where they became
famous
unless you do
real
work serious work on yourself and he did
he's like one of a number of guests
we've had now that who uh has become
sober and all those i mean the common i
know i've said this before but the
common
uh through line is that
they are all have a wisdom because
they've worked on themselves in a way
that
other people don't have by the way this
episode is sponsored by bud light
seltzer i just want to remind you that
that's true
it's true but um drink responsibly
amhezer bush amheiser anderson
and how's your bush saying lose missouri
anyway drink responsibly and you know
not to dwell on his face how many times
we said that but i was studying it
because it's right in front of me and
it looks like the face that i remember
being in high school and wanting
remember that feeling of wanting your
face to look different like oh my i
don't know how i wish my jawline were
more defined there's certain things that
are like the
male the
idea of male beauty being defined in
culture and wanting those things and i
realized
i i that's what it is that his face is
like the definition of
you know like
a an objective
marker of male beauty it is but again i
feel like we shouldn't be dwelling no no
because it gives you so much more than
that and i thought it was so interesting
the way he
he articulated it very well that um to
be reduced to that is like you you
lose your autonomy almost like you lose
a sense of agency or control well you're
objectified yeah he's objectified
yeah and and
people ironically ironically his first
movie the outsiders that we just talked
about um
he got it in part i know he had to go
through a rigorous series of auditions
but he got in part because he was a teen
idol and he was up on that board with
all those
other teen idols yeah of the time like
garrett leaf garrett um
what's his name from charles in charge
oh scott baio that's right willie ames
well see now i wonder if scott bailey i
like i just wonder when it comes to
being healthy having a healthy
perspective of teen idleness
i wonder how those i'd be curious to
talk to them and to know because i i
don't want to mention names but i've
met people who
are still holding on to it you know
and it's very difficult
not to hold on to it like you said the
star quarterback of the football team
yeah who wins the state championship
very very often that guy becomes a 40
year old guy who's still talking about
the championship at night yeah yeah
i think that's very common but
rob lowe has clearly done a lot of work
on himself and
another impressive thing about him his i
want to listen to his podcast because
he is a very good storyteller and i
imagine um
i imagine his podcast is full of those
stories but wasn't that you asked about
the difference between the tv star and
the movie star like the difference
and uh and he had a perfect story about
michael j fox that answered the question
i think people alec baldwin's good at
this too people who
um
use stories
to make their points and then yeah i
know we talked about this with alec
baldwin but it's such an impressive
quality to me that they kind of slip in
uh seamlessly yeah stories um in order
to
make their own in order to enter in
order to uh further the conversation
yeah yeah it's not just like i'm gonna
it's my turn to tell a story yeah yeah
or furthers things or to advance a point
that you made to like amplify your own
exactly and in this case yeah he did
that he did that i know i i sometimes
find myself which is scary i don't want
to like
turn into this person but i find myself
telling stories
because i've been reminded of something
and something there's some
word has triggered a memory
that i think might be entertaining i
mean everyone kind of does that but um
i think some people just do it much
better than others and like you said to
advance the conversation and not in a
selfish way to like hold court and tell
a fun story yeah i i sometimes fear that
i do the
the latter he just seems like he has a
real zest for life and when you asked
him where he'd want to live
if not uh for where he lives now he
he wanted to live in so many different
places and i thought that was
that really told me something about him
you know he like he he wants it all yeah
i want to live in nashville i want to
live in new york i would live in
california
he really has uh like a zest and an
enthusiasm for life and there's a
youthful quality to that to that uh way
of thinking and being and i wonder how
much that has to do with not to get back
to his looks but like
just in terms of his
forget
how his face is set up it's just he
looks so young he looks so youthful
i love his uh i love his dinner of
gorgeous guys it's him and jfk and paul
newman oh yeah
yeah what a gorgeous dude why would he
want that kind of competition well
because he doesn't care about that stuff
that's true he's secure yeah that's why
yeah and i wouldn't be no i'm imagining
myself having roblox roblo's face and i
wouldn't want paul newman around i know
i would want like emilia i really would
i think amelia earhart would be at my i
know that's a hard one for me what would
you talk to her about what are you
kidding nickamor like what happened to
her that's it a lot and her adventures
and her travels and like what it was
like you would bring up at a dinner
party with someone you had never met you
would bring up how she died
that's so rude well i'm sure
i don't think it'd be rude to do that
with a dead person if like like let's
say there's an afterlife and you get to
actually have those discussions with
people like i'm sure people want to talk
about that stuff you have to at least
ease into it though of course i wouldn't
open with that hey amelia uh so nice to
meet you
what is it how do which island did you
crash on like how long did you live of
course you can't do that i would bring i
would i would be the one i'd go out of
my way though to bring up the south
pacific
and i wouldn't order the crab because
you know yeah she got eaten by crabs
apparently uh he's a dolphin he said he
wants to be reincarnated as a dolphin
and then see that who's more of a
dolphin than him yeah how he is
makes perfect sense
yeah smooth he's very smooth uh
um
he when you didn't know you didn't know
that uh literally was his catchphrase on
parks and rec and
you were like oh
yeah
yeah
but you like couldn't commit to saying i
didn't want to i didn't know that i know
but you also couldn't commit to lying
and saying oh of course parks and rec
says
he's in between you're like oh
you know rockwell does sam does that a
lot oh oh when he just knows something
but he doesn't want to be a piece of
oh
oh yeah oh yeah
um i did another i should watch more
parks and rec because people i really i
like parks yeah like you know people
whose sense of humor i'd respect really
like uh one little clarification you
said uh he said bea arthur he loved her
in mod and you confused that with harold
and maude and those are two different
things oh i did mod is a the spin-off is
the show it was it was a sitcom in the
70s
that bea arthur starred in oh and harold
maude is a a movie no i know we were
just talking about that
it's a different kind of mod and i think
he knew that and he didn't want to
correct you because he's charming and
cool
really i i don't have that same problem
i didn't know i did that yeah oh you had
any any opportunity to shame or
challenge
no he's too uh
he doesn't care enough about being right
that's another charming thing
when you don't care that much about
being right i also i also need some more
of that let's read a letter uh you know
i also didn't bring up chad love chad
lois you brought him up i did yeah no
but not about life goes on no oh yeah
i love life goes on you don't both have
to not have you both have to have grown
up with watching life goes on yeah that
was a big show for us uh and so he was
like uh uh um
omnipresent i think i was in a way more
aware of chad lowe for a while than
probably oh for sure
see roblo to me again not to make to get
back to the uh
scandal but he was synonymous more with
that i remember thinking about rob lowe
because i was too young to watch yeah i
was i kind of missed the brat i saw a
lot of those movies just missed it but i
wasn't i was too young when they were we
didn't
exactly yeah i was really into emilio
estevez that was like i thought young
guns yeah from young guns yeah
that was like a formative movie for me
but then i went to see
i saw men at work in the theaters
with charlemagne charlie
i was really into i thought he was the
coolest emilia recipes and that's the
reason i watched the outsiders for the
first time
he's cool and and similar vibe to rob i
i had a lunch with him once
very easy to talk to funny cool cool
cool so so yeah cool the brat pack
they're cool the ones that i might just
get cooler than that yeah i guess the
rat pack is cool too yeah for that
generation but for us for our see you
know the this is gonna be controversial
but i think the brat pack seems cooler
than the rat pack yeah because it was a
time you know how i feel about sinatra
over you think he's overrated
riff lie made to the ding dong ding dong
it's just kind of like this and hey let
me put it this way it's a good actor
frank sinatra is no ben platt
i i agree with that and
probably had a much different uh
perspective on the world yes and
different opinions yes
hey here we go with a letter
ding ding ding and dean martin with a
drink all the time i like sammy davis if
sammy davis is amazing yeah yeah uh very
energy yeah he's incredibly a funny and
great singer
he did it all yeah i do like sammy but i
think dean martin was just kind of like
hey i think along for the ride i think
dean martin is is like like leathery
yeah
oh boy okay let's get some angry dean
martin mail
yeah come at me dean martin fans
and also in dean martin fans defense i
don't know enough about i don't either
he just seems like a hanger on to me you
know but don rick wasn't don rickles
part of the wrapped up uh
i i feel like they were maybe
condescending to him and he he to me is
he's better than all of them oh yeah
yeah let's read a letter okay uh this is
a letter from julie wilson
greetings from indiana
genslinger she says and christian you
know a lot of people call me uh
reference that on instagram i notice
when they when they write things to me
hey genzlinger you really made an impact
on that show yeah there's something
that's a little condescending about it
though but it's also a funny name it is
a funny name yeah kenzlinger big fan of
the show and bigger fan of the christian
justin dynamic oh thanks julie
i grew up with three sarcastic and witty
sisters as the youngest so i appreciate
a lively and fun sibling relationship i
can say i listen to another podcast of
similar design that is very popular and
i typically listen to the interview and
skip the host chat at the end because i
just don't find it to be engaging and
interesting oh that's nice and i'm so
curious who she's talking about
yeah i don't want to don't guess yeah no
because that would be insulting but um
it's nice of her to not have mentioned
that because it would have been
like a snark and she says she likes the
pogba she listens to it uh with your
podcast i find myself anxiously waiting
for the discussions between justin and
christian at the end that's really nice
sometimes i hear little comments during
the interview that i know or hope to
have a little commentary from christian
now can we talk about that sweet drop of
sunshine maggie ah have you read this
letter no
we've only had a small glimpse of her on
the show she's gonna love this
but she's is so positive and bubbly
lovely she can be bubbly
[Music]
you've seen when she's gone a little
flat yeah she's not as carbon well no
one's always bubbling yeah no of course
but bubbly again it's speaking of it's
like the ditzy thing and you have look
what i'm reaching for i'm assuming
bubbly i'm assuming julie doesn't equate
bubbly with ditzy right well we were
just talking about that yeah we're in
the beanie episode yeah um
i just fine or maybe she does
i just find it infectious that's really
nice uh maggie you'll like that i would
love to hear her on the show every now
and again she's gonna love this she will
and you know we try to maggie's been in
the voice memo so if you listen julie if
you listen to after the uh credits at
the end we we include a voice memo and
maybe we'll include her in this one uh
okay so then back to julie good job
christian
i'm not responsible for her personality
but thank you
um also i hope we never have a
definitive answer about the christian
derek jeter debacle because i love
christian's reaction
to fans writing in with their opinion or
facts in quotes about derek jeter's
athletic abilities it's always good for
a laugh
well i feel it seems like so long ago
that debaco was raging uh all in all you
both seem like such fun smart and driven
people driven well oh like part-time
superheroes yeah
yeah um well that's nice of you to say
thanks for taking the time to share a
little of your personalities with all of
us p.s i'm happy the pronunciation of
lacroix
lacroix
now i'm doing it wrong lacroix lacroix
was worked out because that was a real
doozy for me uh oh maybe she's on the
lacroix team
or i think it's lacroix it's supposed to
be lacroix i bet she's on the lacroix
team because we had hemmed in hard too
much about it she was probably like
hemmed
uh would you rather great would you
rather be lo i just love that people are
including these
would you rather be loved by someone you
don't love
or
love someone who doesn't love you back
wow
that is intense would you rather be
loved by someone you don't love
i mean it's about whether or not you
want to feel pain or to inflict pain
right but it but inflicting pain is
painful for me um does it mean would you
rather be in a relationship like this or
just have this person exist in the world
uh it is very i've had both happen to me
and they're both very because if you're
not in a relationship and it's just
someone out there who loves you and you
don't love them back
i would prefer that yeah because it's
selfishly a lot easier to cope but if
the question is i would imagine it's in
a relationship if you're in a
relationship
uh but then you get out of it either way
oh you have to i mean both i think
they're equally terrible but i guess i
would rather
i guess i would rather um
be loved
and not uh and not love back
if i had to pick in a relationship it's
tough though but it is either ways i
would too it's horrible though i mean
that's selfish i know
but i would rather that i suppose
that's really hard yeah thanks julie
[Laughter]
um
yeah that's tough should we do another
would you rather there's another one oh
great oh there is would you rather one
that's less mournful yeah and deep i
don't want to get too deep uh would you
rather lose the ability to read or lose
the ability to speak ooh yeah we read or
speak well you know the problem with
losing the reading is
you read a lot to get by in life
that's just like traffic signs
and traveling would be traveling be
tough you'd have to be told you'd have
to go with guides i guess if you were to
travel anywhere but speak or just
recognize even think about speech how
often i mean i would uh i'd i would
rather lose the ability to read me too
i'm also not a big enough reader yeah
that that wouldn't impact my life as
much as other people maybe yeah i mean
like i don't read like three books a
year
yeah
um but speaking i mean that's all i i
value yeah yeah i would too much um
sincerely julie well thank you julie
those were
uh those were heady and uh
fun
so thank you julie and thank you for uh
the nice things you said about us and
about maggie i know she'll appreciate it
and
i positive and bye second your opinion
yeah so you think she can always be
she's always positive and bubbly yes
always
all right um
uh well so thanks to julie and
uh to who sounds charming in her own
right uh and speaking of charming uh the
one and only rob lowe one of the best
lows the highest of the lows everyone go
listen to his new podcast he has great
guests uh called literally you know what
i want to know more about um
his
days the 80s tearing it up in the 80s
with [ __ ] judd nelson and
j fox i'm sure you'll get a really good
job into it yeah
and if you want to write in uh we love
hearing from you guys and we love
letters and would you rather obviously
our email address is life is short at
wondery.com so thank you to everyone
writing in and listening and uh now
subscribing to roblow's podcast and
we'll talk to you next
[Music]
a week life could be a dream
life short is hosted by me justin long
it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian long as well as megan monaco
senior producer is michelle
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are marshall the
executive producers are marshall
louie and hernan lopez for for wondering
bye stay cold ponyboy oh you have seen
it i know the line
[Music]
bud light seltzer what flavor are you
having
two lemon limes here we go
yeah why are you laughing i don't know
fun
oh sorry
what are your impressions what's your
favorite flavor
um this one's really good but i think
that black
cherry cherries yeah
yeah here's the most important thing do
you know what i'm going to say
oh oh i get i know do you know margaret
what drinking responsibly yeah yeah
trying to close
what are you doing right now sipping
yeah but how is it making you feel good
so are you what are you doing that
responsibly what you're what drinking
response no you're mm-hmm enjoying yeah
yes and how's your bush stainless story
you